[Musique]
bonjour fait sien le vieil homme
aurait coûté alors d'accord soutien
j'accepte que mon apple dit guillaume
j'accepte qu'on appelait guillaume mais
à partir de maintenant je vous appelle
dora l'exploratrice
je mets ce pas je ne comprends pas
abandonné j'ai des bouées 3 reprend bien
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir rappelez vous
quand on va très bien et vous même
ravi de dialoguer avec vous depuis los
angeles je suis totalement accro au
morning show à tel point que j'en ai
oublié l'existence de ritchot de france
j'en ai oublié l'existence de l 2 la
revanche d'une blonde vous êtes
désormais pour moi à des collègues
vous avez la troupe du splendid nous on
a le summer tour c'est pareil on est des
groupe d'humoristes de copains et on est
vachement similaires parce qu'on a fait
un film aussi réalisé par mouloud vous
faites beaucoup d'entrés nous ont fait
beaucoup de sorties
les méchants écoutez aussi le seul film
il ya plus d'acteurs que de spectateurs
c'est
si toute la famille des acteurs étaient
venus au film on l'aurait fait le
million première semaine 34 milliards
d'équipements numériques circulent sur
notre bonne vieille terre les
technologies digitales mobilise 10% de
l'électricité qui est produite dans le
monde et le monde dématérialisé
rejetterait à peu près quatre ou cinq
pour cent des émissions globales de co2
7% 4 % c'est-à-dire un peu moins du
double du secteur aérien civil mondial
la comparaison elle est assez sidérante
autour de cette date je suis reconnaît
tous écologistes oui oui alors il faut
faire les choses les choses c'est ce qui
sort des
générations comme ça de prendre les
choses en main ils sont concrets ils
sont simples ils ont pas de code imei et
comme vous dites c'est ça qui est triste
aussi c'est que eux ils sont déjà dans
des endroits où c'est déjà un peu pas
trop tard il faut pas attendre que ce
soit trop tard quand ça va rassurer de
me dire comment je suis là bas je suis
sur ces chaises quoi je n'étais pas
partie de l'émission côté droit oui
voilà même si ce n'était pas vraiment ça
les règles mais en fait ça va rassurer
de veut dire que je suis encore jeune
mais voilà
une minutes d'utilisation d'internet
dans le monde ça fait tout en une minute
donc il y à un million six cent mille
soit ips sur l'application kindle c'est
à dire qu'ils m'ont expliqué tout à
l'heure soit c'est faire défiler et
choisir ou rejeter les profils de ceux
ou celles qui s'intéressent à vous à
faire un geste du pouce très simples et
très faciles à faire exactement et en
une minute encore il y a un peu plus de
4 millions de recherche google
lors de nos moments de la vie moins du
monde un crime bien fort risque et
hardcore
[Musique]
peut-être
qu'il s'agisse de commander une pizza
aux anchois de réserver un billet
d'avion de regarder une série télévisée
ou bien de trouver l'âme soeur sur un
site de rencontre vient de l'évoquer
internet et le numérique on fait de
chacun de nous des seigneurs moderne
dirigeants du bout de l'index ou du bout
du pouce des armada d'assistants virtuel
produisant la force de travail de
dizaines de serre et autres esclaves
quelques siècles plus tôt ses glaces en
cela dit chaque jour environ 500 lettres
adressées à emmanuel macron sont
ouvertes automatiquement par cette
machine
qu'il vienne d'un citoyen lambda ou d'un
chef d'état tous les courriers passe
ensuite entre les mains de ses six
fonctionnaires
[Musique]
un dessin d'un enfant tu as vu guette
c'est une petite alice elle a 7 ans
monsieur le président j'adore dessiner
mais j'ai fait ce portrait de vous voilà
superman et le super guppy trop vous
attend champions ah oui le superman lui
il appelle superman une nana na na na
pour martin le plus important est de
porter la voix du palais auprès de la
jeunesse de france l'engagement de tous
ces des futurs citoyens et donc ils ont
pris le temps
d'exposer leurs idées et d'exprimer
leurs sentiments et leurs préoccupations
et donc il faut les rassurer sur tout et
il a donné un spa pour l'avenir je vois
qu'il ya un mouvement qui monte qui
consiste à mal accueillir les élèves de
6e et à embêter les élèves nés en 2010
c'est évidemment complètement stupide
c'est contraire à nos valeurs rappelez
vous quand vous étiez 6e vous même
c'était spécial d'arriver au collège et
vous comptiez sur la bienveillance de
tout le monde et bien soyez bienveillant
à votre tour pour les plus chanceux
martin ajoute même une photo dédicacée
du président bien souvent ils ont écrit
fourneaux remercier qu'ils se prennent
en photo avec la photo également voir
une photo de toi avec monsieur
berlusconi alors les berges de saône
iris à la sas et la tv c'était quoi
c'était qu'elle avait chine guen c'était
le fameux lancement de la salle il y
avait christian meurin avec toi ceci dit
c'était un bon patron volailles à
l'époque mais il connaissait très bien
notre métier car exactement après il a
pété les plombs il a fait de la
politique d'étouffement chez cyril et je
me suis dit j'ai assurément pas être là
tu vois quand tu l'aurais stocker c'est
comme quand tu vas
votre très madame série des transferts
scooter garé son secteur il met le
tablier blanc il faut de la sauce tomate
partout et après il fait le tour des
tables quoi qu'il arrive
je vais faire il m'a fait un dîner
incroyable il m'a dit ce que tu aimes
les blondes les brunes les mains sous
les plus tôt italienne sinon moi je suis
assez éclectique mais non maintenant
tout va bien et il me dit est ce que tu
aimes les ferrari oui mais sur une
ferrari dans les animateurs à l'époque
ils ont eu droit à une ferrari ça
révélateur que je ne nommerai pas
toujours dans l'ange vous continuerez
votre discours à aa la traditionnelle
fête de la rose parce qu'elle aura lieu
cette année imaginaire elle aura lieu
ces samedi prochain le 25 sept samedi
prochain samedi prochain fait berner
[Rires]
je salue tous les revenus que les deux
regarde le plus célèbre supporters de
france le marseillais rené malleville
est décédé des suites d'un cancer à
l'âge de 74 ans aujourd'hui le club a
fait part de sa tristesse dans un tweet
et les supporters n'ont pas manqué de
lui rendre hommage avant la rencontre
face à rennes au vélodrome
à l'heure où tous les enfants dorment
johnny est redescendu sur terre à
l'essai
hier
[Applaudissements]
il nous
ces décrets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien parti david hallyday il est parti
oui pourquoi non je voulais lui eut
demandé si son père avait changé de
numéro j'ai laissé qu'un jeu
c'est ma voix là bas si dans toute sa
splendeur et bien heureusement tiré
parti david sylla vient faire